and the amazing thing about this
election is that the Russians are torn
between having to their own Russian Way
of electing a leader which is basically
just you know let's all go to the Falls
and and you know unfold for the guy that
were told to pull for because for
example in December you know in the Duma
elections the genius thing that they did
was you know you you didn't vote for
individual delegates you voted for the
party that then assigned the delegates
so since you voted for the party the
first name on the ballot was Putin's so
basically even if you weren't voting for
Putin you were voting for Putin so you
know the election turned into referendum
on Putin's rule and and there you go so
this time you know it's almost the same
thing because every you know every
opponent is is a bit of a joke there's
this man named Bogdanov who's this
flamboyant sort of dude who wears this
Robert Plant ask you know big hair and
and then of course the old stalwarts you
know organized he's a gun of who's this
you know old communists and communists
are in fact still shockingly the only
viable position there and and then
there's you know your own offski who's
this you know who or no FK is he is
this kind of cross between Rush Limbaugh
and now Sharpton and kind of a
professional rabble rouser who always
seems very comfortable actually in near
power no matter what no matter what
regime is under so you know these guys
are basically clowns and there's only
one possible choice Nevada but at the
same time at the same time it's amazing
to see that the Russians are kind of
adamant about keeping up appearances of
an election there's you know there's a
get out the youth vote initiative for
example I've seen stickers on bus stops
and in shop windows that say you know
supposedly youth friendly things like
the Election Day is as much of a holiday
as your birthday or something and
there's a picture of the birthday cake
or you know or potentially meaningful
one that says you know the elections all
the big questions you know won't be
decided through the internet and there's
like a picture of the sort of okay
button on the computer or something yeah
you know so yeah there's a there's a get
out the youth vote the initiative
there's you know there's editorial so
there's an amazing kind of simulacrum of
excitement that comes exclusively from
top it from top down but it is something
to be seen to be believed
you know what messages are we talking
about you know the message is the only
message that resonates with the public
is strong Russia basically strong Russia
some money in people's pockets those are
the messages that resonate the thing
about the you know the Russian newfound
strength is this is almost entirely
America's doing or the West's I think in
the 90s the Russians have been on the
state level and on the business level
and on the media level they've been
Candice ended to and they've been
pattern eyes in ways that Americans have
a very vague idea about so the thing to
remember about Russians is they feel
incredibly infantilized by by the West
so anybody who comes along and you know
and does these symbolic gestures like
you know like bearing the sort of the
energy teeth a little bit and you know
and playing hardball and Kosovo and
becoming a major player on Iran it's
almost irrelevant what these causes are
what's relevant is that Russia is is you
know throwing its weight around again
and if the West was a little smarter
they would actually allow Russia to do
that in kind of mutually agreed safe
you know the situations for example
North Korea and around where Russia can
you know act very macho and actually be
useful at the same time but you know
unfortunately the West hasn't been
handling it too well and now you know
we're reaping the fruits of that well
yeah I mean Russia has some interesting
rules for the election process itself
they are actually harder on
electioneering right you know right sort
of in the run-up to the elections and
you know then Americans are but at the
same time it's like a fine house in
version of of our electoral process
because there's you know for for example
no debates right or or the television
that's you know covering the candidates
in a following way this is something
that I've heard on Russian TV this was
kind of priceless they were basically
saying you know the anchor and channel
one was saying well Dugan of you know
the Communist opponent of Medvedev you
know spent the day doing you know this
promotional appearance here and
promotional appearance there and you
know book Don of did that and only one
candidate was brave enough to forego
this ridiculous charade and to
concentrate instead on working for the
well-being of the Russian people that
candidate was natrium Advaita you know
so basically they create a situation
where there is no campaign to speak of
and Medvedev comes from such a position
of power kind of magic Authority if you
will that the very fact that he doesn't
engage in campaigning makes him look
more dignified because campaigning is
you know campaigning is just jostling
for a second place and you know that's
the way people seem to like it
the European managers for the elections
are actually going to be boycotting the
elections as you might know and it's not
that they have been kicked out but you
know the right now it's basically it's
one of those ridiculous soviet-style
situations when when Russia says well it
was their goal to be you know kicked out
it was their goal to boycott us from the
beginning so that they could make a
political statement and you know and
what do you answer to that and then of
course there's this big flap with with
the so-called European Institute that
was also going to provide some
monitoring and they were just kicked out
of their building a citing violations of
fire code or you know something like
that so obviously there are attempts to
minimize the monitoring of the elections
the funny thing about it for me is that
they don't really have to do it because
I believe that people will genuinely
vote for innovative and that's the
amazing thing about Russian elections
because the popularity of mr. Putin is
such that I don't see a point of rigging
them he would still win you know and his
party would still win in December and me
that it would still been maybe by 65% of
the vote not you know 87 or 89 or
whatever they're going to receive but I
suppose the reasoning inside the Kremlin
is that you just can't leave these
things to count
you